I'm not a bigot but I'm calling me a
racist history I'm a racist
damn right I'm erasing I don't hide that
I'm gonna race this person but I'm not a
bigot I don't hate anybody but I'm a
race is a race is somebody that loved
the race and loved their people all
right Steven Steven where'd you grow up
where you from originally I grew up in
New Albany Mississippi tell me about
your childhood you had both your parents
growing up as a kid my dad wasn't really
in my life that much my dad was a
Vietnam veteran he had a lot of health
issues he living in my life a lot I
think I got my dad got my life when I
was about 16 years old and my mother
practically raised me and my brother
herself and you know also you know I had
a mother that was a very strong
religious woman that raised me my
brother so you know I had a good
childhood I don't I can't complain I had
a stern mother that you know that taught
me you know to be an honest person and a
good person so you know I had a decent
childhood I really did what kind of kid
were you in high school I was a loner
I stayed to myself because I still to
this day I can't tolerate certain people
I just can't and it's not really a
racial issue issues I can't I can't be
around a bunch of people I just don't
like being around them was there racism
in your family I grew up when I grew up
in a time when the riots in LA was going
on you know I'd be watching TV and stuff
like that and you'd see when they pulled
that oh boy that truck in LA you know
the Rodney King stuff and I grew up in a
very racial time so I grew up in a time
where where this stuff was not being
forced down me but maybe at the time I
shouldn't have seen that as a child but
this was something that I seen a lot you
know it wasn't hidden from me racial
stuff was not hidden from me so yes it
was a part of my life it was a part of
my childhood you know it was Mississippi
Burning when I was kid always looked up
to the ku ku ku Klux Klan I always
admired the Ku Klux Klan I always said
I'd be a great leader one day I always
said that
did you have relatives that were in the
class my grandfather was a very racial
person but I'm not gonna say he was a Ku
Klux Klan member but no I mean I this
the Klan thing is something that I took
on my home it's something that I knew as
a child that I'd do this this is my
calling this has always been my column
so you're the Imperial wizard I'm the
end I'm an imperial wizard that's the
highest rank as far as the Ku Klux Klan
yeah and Mississippi is one of the
strongest states for the class it is
it's one of the mother Mississippi white
knights is one of the most respected
groups as far as the Ku Klux Klan goes
we have the most respect I had left the
Mississippi white knights for a little
bit and joy started North Mississippi
white knights but now we're gonna bring
it back we're gonna get everything
situated again get the Calabrian in
order and start everything back over
again so yes I've just kind of just
moved back from Portland Oregon so I was
I lived there for years it's very
different but I did love it I love the
weather
I loved Beatty and there's a lot of
white people there but they're liberal
minded they have no idea that was I was
I was married to a girl on a Norwegian
girl and her family was very liberal in
mind setting judgmental people they
judge me for being in because I'm no
longer married to her but at the time
that was the love of my life and it
didn't work out it just didn't work out
because people are judgmental they're
too judgmental about everything you do
in your life and at the end of the day
they need to look under their doorstep
and sweep and see what they've got going
on in their life most people that judge
me for being in a Klu Klux Klan and hate
me for being in clothes clam there's an
underlining reason for that they're gay
they're homosexual or a race mixer no
something like that but I give I don't
judge anybody I'll give anybody a chance
but if you want to judge me and say hey
this is that it's wrong for the Ku Klux
Klan then I'm gonna judge you you're
giving me an open door to judge you so
I'm not really a judgmental person I
don't force my beliefs on anybody until
they want to judge me so interesting
so the so the South is notorious for
racism there's a long history of slavery
segregation all kinds of all kinds of
issues that you guys the poverty thing
is that that we have like I said I lived
in Washington state I live in Portland
Oregon and we have a lot more freedoms
here than I did up there
so there's positive and negatives about
the state of Mississippi but I love the
set of Mississippi is my home I love it
there's great things about the state of
Mississippi and I love it and the blacks
tend to won't have a reason to [ __ ]
sorry about my language they want to
have a reason to gripe they want to have
a reason to throw a fit they want to
have a reason to to tear [ __ ] up and and
and that's where the Ku Klux Klan comes
in to put a stop to it and say it's not
going to happen you know I've had
corrupt cops in City to blow lose their
job because Ku Klux Klan was involved
because we wasn't gonna have it
I wasn't gonna have it I stood up for my
people in the city of Tupelo and instead
of Mississippi but blacks blamed it on
their self they do they but they're like
this officer that got shot in the line I
mean that offered that shot the guy in
Atlanta took his taser man but people
don't understand if you read the Turner
Diaries it plainly says it that if you
if you if you get the long that's the
last line of defense between us and
communism if you get rid of law
enforcement if you get rid of law
enforcement then that gives them a new
communist an open door to come in and
take over and we and I've got a 19 year
old daughter and and and that era her
age around that age is gonna be the
worst the worst I don't know what this
country's couldn't become because
they're freeloaders they're never third
they don't want to work I don't want to
smoke dope they don't want to work they
don't want they one with data on one day
right and you know and I try to instill
that in my daughter and I try to tell my
daughter you know that is gonna be the
worst generation ever you know my
generation was slacking on a lot of
things but but that era that generation
is going to be we're [ __ ]
I mean we're this country folk but
that's where the Ku Klux Klan is gonna
come in and say we're not gonna have
you know we're not gonna have one I'm
gonna put up with it
where's the basic idea behind the clam
it's not just as simple as racism right
my my belief and my goal for the Ku Klux
Klan is it's not really a it is a racial
funny because you got to be we can only
be white to be in the clip close Klan
but my goal for the Ku Klux Klan if to
protect this country from all-out
invasion from anything from any type of
thing the goal of a Ku Klux Klan is for
the Advancement of the white race I'm
not a bigot but I'm a white separatist
I'm not a white supremacist I don't
consider myself my race superior but we
have to have organizations for like the
Ku Klux Clinton still the children and
the people that want to join to teach
them that there's a greater cause
there's a greater cause being a Klansmen
is when the greatest things in the world
I mean it's it's I love it I wouldn't
take anything for it and my judge I
don't give us just one thing about me I
don't care what anybody says about me
you can judge me you can say anything
you want about me it doesn't affect me
because the minute that a person takes
time out of their day to judge me and
say I'm wrong when I'm this and that I
mean I've got to them I've affected them
because I don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
else does I don't but the minute that
they take time it's like my people come
to my rallies and they make them signs
up in all this [ __ ] you took time out of
your day to go make a sign go by that
marker go by that poster board I
affected you I have one it's an
accomplishment for me so you know so
separatism is a big part of the class I
think that I think that the the the the
only way that the white wait forever
survive the white race will ever survive
is we separate and now I'm not saying
that we get rid of the blacks I'm saying
that give the blacks just like the
Indians give them their own homeland
give them where they need to go give
them just as much rights as a white man
does but you put the biggest biggest
wall up like Donald Trump building on
the southern border and what the way
it's separating your separate the whites
and blacks are separated that's the only
way we're going to survive and so the
same thing applied to gay and Mexican no
it's gonna be hard for me to say this
but
love is a hell of a thing and it's gonna
be really odd for me to say this but
love seats no color in some ways it's
weird for me to say that but it's the
truth love does not see a color but you
got to love somebody that doesn't mean
if you get with a black person you sell
out your race you sell you you act black
and you sell out your race you love a
person not further color but for who
they are as an individual doctor didn't
I say you love seasonal color and I took
me a while to get to that point I guess
living in Portland
told me that but you know I'll be
experienced if you get out of the state
of Mississippi and you go other places
and you experience things you find that
love is love is an odd thing it's an odd
thing it's worse than any drug you can
have in your life
I find saying I married the love of my
life and I'm still in love with her but
it's over and done with but you don't
see it you don't see a color when it
comes to love you don't but that meant
but you still need to have love for your
race you need to have love for your
people and in trainers race-mixing wrong
race-mixing is exactly wrong you stay
with your people but the your x-bike was
white oh yeah definitely are you
religious mm-hmm
I'm a Baptist but the Klan is a
Christian organization yeah well
Christian that's what we're about
I consider us like that I said it before
like the Taliban or al-qaeda I do
consider us that we're technically the
same thing we already just like they are
hot fighting I said before about our
fighting a holy war we are fighting a
holy war for the Christianity for our
race and for Arab people that's what
we're fighting for have I done anything
illegal no about if I've been to prison
no I've never been to prison but I will
always stand up for my race and if it
was ever a point to where I ever had to
go to prison for doing the right thing
and standing up for my race I'd do it
I just have one Russellville Alabama mmm
cross Lighting's yeah and they're still
hangings of black men in Mississippi
I've seen news I don't think that's Klan
related no I wouldn't know that that was
clan related I'm telling you for a fact
if that happened if a clan from went out
and hung a black man in the state of
Mississippi I'd be the first one to know
that
well you're the head of the organization
I'm a leader brother Richard is is is my
leader but I'm an imperial brother
Richard and pillars are but right now
and where the Richard is the man that
told me everything I know
so the Klan is smaller now than it was
when you were younger right no no I'm
not wrong y'all know what made any much
Klan around but now we're there's so
many underground clans many cuz on I
don't know it's like a lot of people
when Donald Trump got elected they think
the white supremists are just rampid it
hit the white white sir mister just
ramping it's not true we have stopped
like I live like I said I lived in
Washington State Portland and I come
back home and it's amazing me how
nobody's doing nothing stand tall for
what you believe in
fight for this [ __ ] and and get yeah
that's what my mom now I'm home and
we're gonna be home we're gonna straight
and say to Mississippi how did having a
black president for eight years affect
you in any way the thing is about Barack
Obama's a lot of people said that Barack
Obama was worse than Jimmy Carter I
didn't I don't care who the president is
that doesn't affect me I'm not a Donald
Trump really support I do support some
of the [ __ ] that Donald Trump does but
Donald Trump also says a lot of dumb
[ __ ] if he'd keep his mouth shut
he'd be in a lot better shape and that's
the truth but I have I love the
president I love Donald Trump wasn't a
fan of Obama wasn't a fan of of Bush but
in anything when when it's like the Klan
was more awake when Obama was in there
now that trumps in there it's like we've
quit and it's not gonna happen
I'm gonna be the gasoline and the match
that's I'm gonna fire to like this [ __ ]
back up and I'm gonna light it back up
and I can do it I'm telling you gasoline
we gonna pour some gasoline on this [ __ ]
like this somebody's gonna be wide open
so so do you see whites as superior to
other races I never said that I'm not
I'm not I'm not I mean I'm not no I'm
not a white supremacist I'm not no I'm
not I don't consider my world race
superior to anybody but we do have a lot
of accomplishments that that is lit left
out that we've done a lot of great
things I'm a white separatist I believe
that we should be separated but I don't
consider the white race superior to
anybody I believe that the white race is
the most beautiful thing in the world
it's like do you mean when we talk about
my ex-wife it's up to you and we're not
gonna mention your name
okay so I don't see how somebody then
I'm gonna teach them about the beauty of
the white race somebody can be Norwegian
my ex-wife for Norwegian ancestry how
you can be a Norwegian or you can be
anything European and then sell your
race out not be proud of your race the
Norwegian people are some of the most
beautiful is a Bea beautiful it's
beautiful women I mean it the woman I
was married to was amazing that was my
trophy wife I guess you could say and
but how can you be I'm English ancestry
but how can you be German or anything
like that I consider that no it's all
the white race but that is a superior
you want talk about superiority
Norwegian anything like that that is a
superiority of the white race but how
can you not be proud of that if you want
also a superior that is superior at that
ancestry like I said I'm English
ancestry I'm Howard you know my people
come from England so most people in the
South are that you know their English
ancestry so but how can you be a period
I'll call that pure Aryan race and not
be proud of that and not not not stand
up for that I don't I don't it amazes me
how that happens it amazes me
I don't like race traitors I don't like
race mixers because that's killing off
the white race now like I Stan always
I'm not
I'm not a white supremacist I'm a white
separatist I believe that whites and
blacks should be separated I don't
believe in race mixing I believe that
race mixtures are the worst part that
are ruining the white race I've had I've
had a black woman tell me that that she
would never be with a black man because
the way the black men are this is coming
out of a black woman's mouth a black
woman that I knew you know everybody's
got mammy or whatever it's a black woman
that practically raised me as a child
but babysitting me as a child command me
you know and that woman tell me to this
day she's an older woman to me to this
day should never be able to black him
here now how do you feel about the black
lives matter the movement itself I don't
know much about it I'm gonna be honest
with you I can't I can't wrap my whole
mind around what what that is
I can't what what is that a political
organization is it is it a black it's a
premise organization they have a right
to be proud to be black but black life
matter it they are to me they're a black
supreme it's for organization and that's
why you need organizations like the Ku
Klux Klan to say we're not gonna have
that we're gonna stop that I've the
front end black lives matter in Tupelo
before the Klan when I was a young child
like I said I looked up to the Ku Klux
Klan I always wanted to be a clan for me
but the Klan has bettered me as an
individual I have people that come up to
me and be like man I know who you are
local celebrity around here I'm called
literally people I've worked with or
people I know call me the local
celebrity I don't consider myself a
celeb and consider myself better than
anybody I put my britches on just like
anybody else does anything that I've
done in the Ku Klux Klan I try I try to
tell these other guys stand up take your
take take take charge like I said put
the gasoline put the match like this
[ __ ] up and let's go let's do it
and and the Klan has always as has
bettered me financially if I needed
anything food kids anything the Klan has
always been there for me it's made me a
better individual Smith it's put
something
I'm proud to be something that I can
look up to myself so you know they can
say what they want to about me but I've
always tried to the better thing for my
race for my country in the Mississippi
White Nights and I'll continue to do
that the Klan is is is if anybody wants
to be a client
anybody wants to be a Klansmen take that
chance in life
do it because you won't regret it is it
hard at times well it costs you
relationships yeah but if a woman can't
stand behind you for the should say well
I'm not gonna be with you here in the
Klan you don't need her anyway she's
looking for a reason they need to accept
you that's what that's what that's what
women need to understand that if you
want to look we the women women the
white women have now turned into
something that I had blows my mind it
blows my mind the beauty of the white
race I'll sell it out they'll sell down
with a [ __ ] they'll sell down with
Mexican men say that they'll settle down
they'll do anything but they won't did
the white man a chance and I hit both my
mind and if a woman wants a real good
man and a respectable man she's look for
Klansmen because of a claim that's gonna
stand tall for what he believes in I'm
not a coward I don't cover my face I
will never come when I joined this
organization I joined this organization
to be a leader to take charge to be a
role model for other men I want to never
hide my face because of Klansmen the
Klan is the greatest thing that has ever
come in my life and I do not regret it
love it so it's Juneteenth this weekend
will you be celebrating about that I
don't know much about that holiday I
don't know I know it's freed the slaves
or whatever but I believe that I believe
that's when we brought them over here we
better that race if they think they've
got it so bad over here take yes back to
Africa I will gladly pay for a boat trip
for a boat loaded in [ __ ] and
take them back to I will pay for it I
will rent the boat and pay for that
sumbitch's they don't like it in this
country gladly pay the ticket I will pay
the ticket I mean I will set up a pay
Pal account sending blacks back to
Africa donate and I put them on a cruise
ship
I'm have fun while they're going back to
Africa they won't like it and they'll
come their ass back over here
no all right Steven thank you for thank
you for talking with me and sharing your
views it's a very interesting stuff
thank you
you